this animation is brought to you by the
smart image base a subscription website
where you can download thousands of
medical images and videos to use in
lectures courses presentations
professional training and more for more
information click on the link in the
description
independent variable and dependent
variable are important terms related to
controlled experiments
remember a controlled experiment is a
scientific test in which all conditions
are kept constant
except for the variable you're testing
the independent variable is the thing
you're testing in an experiment
it's often abbreviated as iv
and sometimes called the manipulated
variable because you change or
manipulate this variable
in an experiment the dependent variable
is the thing you're observing and
measuring the thing you're anticipating
may be affected as a result of exposure
to the independent variable
it's often abbreviated as dv
and sometimes called the responding
variable because it responds to the
change that you make
let's look at a few examples
suppose your hypothesis is that if
students study 15 minutes a night then
they will have higher test grades than
those who don't study at all
what's being changed or manipulated it's
whether or not the students study for 15
minutes
and what's going to be observed or
measured in this experiment
what do you think might be different as
a result of this increased study time
you're expecting test grades will be
affected
in this experiment the independent
variable is the study time
and the dependent variable the thing
you're measuring or going to observe
is the test grades
here's another example
see if you can figure it out
this time the hypothesis is that if
people who have headaches take aspirin
then they will get relief faster than
those who don't take aspirin for
headaches
so what's the thing that's different in
this case
the thing that's different the
independent variable is whether or not
somebody is taking an aspirin
then what are you going to measure
you're measuring how long it takes for
their headache to go away
that's the dependent variable
here's a final example to help you
understand these terms
predict that if a brand name light bulb
is left on continuously then it will
burn longer than a bargain brand light
bulb used in the same manner
in this case what is the independent
variable
it's the brand name light bulb
what are you measuring
you're measuring how many hours the
light bulbs work before burning out
which is the dependent variable
the independent variable is the brand
name light bulb and the dependent
variable is the amount of time the light
bulbs work before burning out
so to review
the independent variable is the thing
that you're testing
sometimes this is referred to as the
cause in an experiment it is also the if
part of your hypothesis
the dependent variable the thing you're
measuring is the effect
it is also the then part of your
hypothesis
[Music]